if you care about it then you think well
I'm going to do the little I can do and
together we can just lick some dent it
is horrible but you have to tough it out
Ingrid Newkirk welcome thank you
very excited to meet you so first I want
to tell you a very difficult woman to me
in terms of what to wear because I
stopped dressing I don't feel
comfortable wearing all my wool coat I
normally wear leather shoes and I really
have to rethink what I was wearing this
morning it's easy nowadays you know it
wasn't at one time but if you set out to
do it leather that's made of grapes of
pineapple of mushrooms Stella McCartney
of course icon of fashion that has
metallic threads and all these
extraordinary materials that you never
sort of the foot and for practicality as
well as fashion but most people still
haven't heard of them what and where are
they who are these brands who are who
are creating an amazing clothes cause as
your readers do read the fashion press
you've come across new things all the
time and some of them are quite pricey
but it's becoming mainstream especially
these breathable vegan leathers now
we've been in China and we've seen dogs
killed for leather that comes into this
country obviously not marked as a dog
leather but you can't tell you never
know as we say whose skin you're in and
of course we have been on the cattle
trail in India of all places and that is
a horrific trail where the cattle are
abused so awfully for a leather satchel
or leather handbag I can't imagine
anyone with a kind heart who just
glimpses what we've seen would do
anything other than seek out these new
vibrant exciting fashion items that are
not the product of cruelty the furphy
conversation has been around for a long
time and most people I know wouldn't
touch bear with a bargepole
however leather and wool
I've been a newer conversation yes
climate is so free it was husband but we
feature low though we feature war and we
don't think about it for my conscious
perspective what do you think is
changing well I'm so old now that I
remember the day when people said
exactly that about fur they had no idea
and they would say oh come on it can't
involve such cruelty now as you say
unless you've lived in a cave you know
that the same thing is happening
ever so slowly but I can see the
avalanche approaching because the expose
is are shocking and the alternatives are
now available so it simply is a matter
of the consumer pushing the market going
online and saying I'm choosing this one
not that one recently
booooo-whoo came out saying that they
were going to ban wool and then I don't
know a week later they said actually
we're not going to burn more because
it's not good for sustainability and I
think that conversation is really
interesting because we wear fake fur and
that's really bad for the environment
because it sits in a landfill for a
thousand years
so where where does that conversation
stick in terms of ethical versus
sustainable fake fur is actually far
more environmentally conscious nots it
totally it isn't then real fur real fur
has to be treated with what are called
Morton's which are a huge cocktail of
chemicals and they use things that are
not only poisonous to the environment to
treat the flesh to make it so that
doesn't rot they treat it so that if you
throw a piece of out of your window
it'll still be there years and years
later it doesn't biodegrade this is a
fantasy come and go back to the very
beginning because obviously you loved
animals I read that you had a dog that
you know like my children you grew up
from birth does it from birth of a dog
that was your best friend but how do you
go from being an animal lover which I am
into thinking I can set up what is going
to become the world's biggest plant in
close to organization
and how to make that step how old were
you where did you even start well thanks
for mentioning my brother the dog
because he was there before I got there
he was my parents child before I arrived
so it didn't occur to me as an only
child with this dog that there was any
difference in his feelings and mine and
there really wasn't by eight animals I
had my first fur coat when I was 19 I
first but later it occurred to me
they're all Shawnee my dog's name
they're all the same when I had that
thought it occurred to me if I cared
about animals maybe I should start a
little group and trying to show people
how bad things are for animals and how
we're at this point well I started
working for animals when I was 19 and I
formed the group PETA in 1980 and I know
seven demons here the inspiration ladies
really my heart has been broken million
times on the videos that we've seen the
sheep-shearing one believe it or not if
you care about animals it will crush you
to jump by the work food never to raise
and I got that wrong she did she Allen
teared for Mother Teresa so I'd be okay
with orphans stray dogs all sorts of
refugees that never home Wow and she
said it doesn't matter who suffers it
matters that they suffer try to do
something about it so I learned from her
amazing for all the amazing things that
Peter has done and you have done since
1980 you face an awful lot of criticism
as well along the way before some of the
tactics you've used using scantily clad
women at Wimbledon how do you feel about
the backlash that you get in those
situations every woman who does it and I
mean just don't turn away but I've done
it okay there's a five years ago I heard
from
and the smella feels heat markets work
the pig carcasses so it's not all about
sex but even where did I make it yes
totally absolutely nothing to ditch on
you know I think anybody else to do
something you did not at all every woman
who's doing it is entitled to keep her
clothes on I'll take them off as she
chooses no one has paid to do this we're
not using women I women are saying I'll
do it
you've had huge successes a lot of
fashion labels over the search you
stopped selling fur and there are lots
of other brands and I knew how to to
accessories are which is obvious one of
my favorites or issues today tell me
what's the relationship was our
impediment I just adore Zara I think
they're an ethical company and when we
went to China and we saw how the rabbits
a live plucked for angora honestly
that's the worst video we share about
that I wish that the others weren't as
bad but we went to Zara management and
the corporate executives showed it to
them and we said come with us to China
and they said yes we'll all go together
now companies usually don't do that that
you're scared and we did go and what
they saw horrified them they came back
they said absolutely no more angora they
had a million pounds worth of angora on
their shelves we said that doesn't wash
with us they gave it all to us and we
sensed that angora to refugees and
Afghanistan and other places to children
who were freezing in the winter cold and
they sacrificed that profit in order to
do something as the color I love Zara
how can gamma read as an audience how
can they actively get involved if they
care about these
I adore you for asking the question
because it is the most vital question
there is and signing a petition is fine
but it really doesn't do that much but
really the amount of money you spend in
a year on food on clothing
it's your buying decisions that are
worth thousands of pounds and it's your
voice managing to show someone one of
those videos online on your social media
talking to someone about something
you've tried perhaps a piece of clothing
a sandwich
that's what makes the difference I'm
going to show you out thank you thank
you